will the U.S dollar collapse it's a
question a lot of people are asking a
lot of videos are going viral on
Instagram Tick Tock oh my God what would
happen if the US dollar as a currency
world currency is replaced with somebody
else because what's going on with bricks
you're seeing China and Russia become
best friends you've seen a potential
peace deal Iran and Saudi Arabia Brazil
is there with Lula with these guys what
would happen if they start buying oil
through one and this is going to be bad
for America I'm telling you this is what
we have to worry about well who's right
who's wrong we don't know here's what we
do know since 1450 there's only been six
different world currencies and when you
find the data you can easily make the
argument why the US dollar will be
replaced or you can also make the
argument to say not anytime soon let's
get right into it
thank you
okay so if you get value from this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into a couple
different things what is a world Reserve
currency when you hear about this what
does this really mean what that is is
it's the currency that is held in
significant quantities by governments
institutions as a means of international
payments foreign exchange reserves and
Investments so in other words it's the
most liquid Capital that's available in
the international market for people to
use in exchange for whatever it may be
and that happens to be today the US
dollar so you know the whole thing about
currency like what happens if the US
dollar collapses and we're using a
different currency what's gonna maintain
their value anything that's a
non-duplicatable asset such as What
alternative Investments right such as
art because when you look at Art last
year did you know last year the three
auction houses had a record break in
Europe 18 billion dollars of art sold
last year and so many companies like
Goldman Morgan all these other companies
are sitting there recommending their
clients to look at alternative
Investments so specifically within the
art space and a one company that's
disrupting this industry right now is
Masterworks and here's how they're doing
it the average person cannot go buy a
Picasso cannot go buy a Banksy or a
Warhol and say oh my God I can't buy
something like that's three million
dollars I can't buy something like that
is 2.8 million dollars but anybody can
go buy a share of it and that's what
happens with Masterworks they now have
over 700 000 users that are part of
Masterworks and anybody can go buy a
shirt and it's just like stock you're
buying within a company it's all
regulated it's all through SEC and by
the way two things you need to talk
about Masterworks every single piece of
art that they sold they provided net
profits to investors and last year alone
2022 they paid 25 million dollars to
their investors so if you want to
participate with what Masterworks that's
going on click on the link below go get
registered or learn for yourself and you
feel comfortable start diversifying by
investing in alternative assets with
Masterworks okay so let's take a look at
the six major world currencies we've had
since 1850 believe it or not the first
one was Portugal from 4 1450 to 50 30
lasted 80 years this is during the Age
of Exploration Portugal created a
dominant Global Empire
Ottoman Empire closed off the
traditional trade route to Asia forced
Innovation through advanced and
navigational technology the Portuguese
were able to reach Africa Asia and the
new world Portuguese currency became the
primary currency used in global trade
and it established military outposts
along the coast of Africa India Malaysia
Japan and China they became overextended
the Empire eventually declined due to
attacks and competition from other
countries mainly the Dutch British and
the French you would never guessed
Portugal would you have but they would
have first second of Spain which by the
way lasted the longest 110 years from
1530 to 1640 combined forces with
Portugal to form the Iberian Union
Spanish silver coins were the first
Global Reserve currency recognized in
Europe Asia and Americas and this
happened due to Abundant silver supplies
from Spanish South America eventually
they collapsed through Wars and
revolutions by the mid 1600s next one is
Netherlands which lasts 80 years from
1640 to 720 they had their rights to
Global power resulted from creation of
the Dutch East India Company first
publicly traded multi-international
Corporation in the world founded to
protect that state-spice trait in the
Indian Ocean and to assist in the Dutch
war of independence from Spain the Dutch
defeated Portugal and Spain economically
by positioning themselves to profit from
European demands for spices France and
England started their own spice trading
companies and went to war with the Dutch
saturated Spice Market and the costly
Wars destroyed the Dutch as a Global
Currency next is France which lasted 95
years from 1720 to 1815 France was best
positioned to be the next Reserve
currency achieve European dominance
under Louis XIV but he put France and
massive debt caused by War and
extravagance parties implemented heavy
taxes something were similar with here
in the states the 1789 French Revolution
was caused by an economic turmoil and
public outrage after a decade of Civil
War Napoleon takes over so this guy
trying to pull you'll like a lot of
words obviously we know about that but
it lasted from 1803 to 1815 conquered a
lot of territory eventually overextended
himself and now comes a new currency
Great Britain next one the financial cap
of the world London 105 years from 1815
to 1920 after Napoleon's defeat at the
Battle of Waterloo in 1815 England
dominates global trade for 105 years
Industrial Revolution combined with
Advanced shipbuilding capabilities to
being an island nation made them the
most dominant maybe in the world
dominant Navy equals dominant global
trade the Sun never set on Great Britain
was a saying they said for decades
during that time and then eventually
World War One destroyed Great Britain's
economy and position as a reserve
currency took on a massive amount of
debt to win the war the U.S benefited
massively from World War one and every
country from both sides of World War One
were borrowing money from the U.S to pay
the U.S to build things for them and
during World War One the U.S started
transitioning from a under
industrialized Agri agricultural economy
to the industrial manufacturing
Powerhouse it eventually became so then
comes the United States which is kind of
tricky because some states started in
1920 which means the U.S currency has
been the world currency for 103 years
but some say it happened in 45 which is
only 78 years let me tell you why you
know those that say became the world
currency in 1921 it was because we had
the healthiest economy in the world
during the World War one that was taking
place so automatically it's like well we
think U.S dollar is going to be the
currency however technically the dollar
did not become the official Reserve
currency until the post 1944 Bretton
Woods agreement and after World War II
the U.S basically had all the gold in
the world and because of that countries
around the world agreed to treat the US
dollar as an equivalent to gold and the
dollar was redeemable in Gold until
1971. which kind of changed the game and
that's why a lot of people are saying
what is the dollar backpack today at
least in 1970 was a dollar was backed by
gold but how about today it's more risky
it's more fragile it is a very good
argument a lot of people people make the
dollar has been the reserved currency
enough for either 102 years or 79 years
depending on how you look at the start
date so for the people that say this
will never happen to the dollar what
makes the dollar so much more powerful
that it'll never happen to this they'll
say well the infrastructure that we
spend decades building or we have the
most money circulating or most goods are
priced out by the US dollar or the fact
that we've had a lot of momentum and all
these momentum year after year after
year and it's a habitual thing that
we've been doing it's like listen I'm
just using a US dollar it's gonna be so
hard to get away from it but as we know
Innovation Works think about an app use
five years ago you're not even thinking
about it today Groupon let's just say
you know everybody was on Snapchat and
then there was something everybody was
using us the change is so quick with
technology so what needs to happen for
us to move on to a new currency so you
would need a currency capable of
handling trillions of dollars of trade
per day several hundred thousand
transactions per second and even bigger
than that a government that others would
trust so if you know we're going to go
to one you trust China but we're gonna
have a new world currency that
everyone's going to be using do you
trust or all governments coming together
to use one is their trust level high for
somebody who want to do that by the way
one of the things that we did think
about for for those that say it'll never
happen it's not going to happen during
my lifetime I'm only 28 years old it
happens seven years from now maybe but
not right now okay what did we learn
during covet we learned how much we
relied on Taiwan for chips we learned
how much we relied on China for our
Pharmaceuticals manufacturing China if
there was anything that happened during
covet it was a big commercial to the
world to say you rely on China okay we
all felt it and they stood up tall and
said hey you need us you made a mistake
years ago doing all this stuff for us
and we were winning on the backs of use
at U.S but too late now because you know
you need us I was like Hey Apple's
moving away from China to go to India
well there's some reliability we're
leaning on China for some of this stuff
so again whether that causes anything or
not is irrelevant but one has to to be
paranoid to think that there is a
possibility because during covet we were
definitely relying on China a lot I may
just convince you to say well Pat that's
the case we're definitely going to go to
one well let's argue myself on what is
the global one reserves worldwide
comparable to the US dollar Reserve
worldwide this is what it's looking like
so if you look at the global Reserve
currency you'll see US dollar all the
way at the top at around 60 percent then
you have the Euro then you got the Yen
and all the way at the bottom you see
what that is Brandman b r b it's what
the one is for China it's not even close
so for that to happen a lot would need
to change but some people say well Pat
the US dollar share of global central
bank reserve is the lowest we've had in
30 years we can look at that as well and
if you see this charge with a lot of
panic of where we are today you would
see that from 1979 to 1996 it was lower
than what it is today but if we go back
and think about when we were the
strongest it's all the way back from 70
to around 78 until the president the guy
named Jimmy Carter showed up was the
closest president we've ever had to
Jimmy Carter was a guy named Joe Biden
so that's another fear a lot of people
are having on what's going to happen to
our currency I want to show you these
two charts just for you to look at see
on what the dollar the power of the
dollar is today if you look at this one
here it shows the sheriff
over-the-counter foreign exchange
transactions you see the blue that's U.S
look what percentage of it is blue U.S
orange is Euro then you have the pound
which is green then the light blue is
the Yen the pink is other you see that
small little yellow right there that's
the Chinese one see how small it is it
ain't that big then look at this other
chart when it comes down to share of
export invoicing in Americas it's pretty
much the US dollar in Asia Pacific it's
again pretty much a US dollar 70
something percent of the time a small
percentage is Euro pink is other in
Europe they pretty much use the euro
orange is Europe but if you look at also
the rest of the world eighty percent of
time is a US dollar so the US dollar as
of today it's still the main currency
everybody use it closing thoughts Henry
Kissinger once said the following who
controls the food supply controls the
people who controls the energy can
control the whole continent who controls
money can control the whole world and
you know who controls money U.S controls
money now sometimes when you have a lot
of power and it's been around for a
while you become entitled you become
arrogant you become soft you create
blind spot you start looking at the
outside as the enemies Vanderbilts had a
lot of money all their money you know
how long they lasted two generations you
know why because one of the sons all he
wanted to do was spend the money and
party and us right now spending money as
if we have money forever and if I the
enemy is looking at us if there's ever
been an opportunity to go in there in a
creative way whether it's Global cbdc
whether it's buying some U.S politicians
and leaders whether it's dividing
America internally whether it's any of
those manipulative ways to hurt America
this is a great season for it am I
saying it can have the next 12 months 24
months 36 months five years ten years no
but can it happen next 10 15 20 years
yes if the US gets too cocky and
comfortable somebody else can come and
take our lunch and then all of a sudden
everyone's looking around saying what
happened to the US it can happen that
quickly because technology moves very
quickly having said that if you got
value from this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel I got
another video I want you to watch about
cbdc if you've never seen it click here
to watch it take care everybody bye
bye-bye
foreign